[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
serv laurent cher gérard cher françois
xavier
merci à valérie et je m'associe à tout
tout ce que tu as fait et surtout tous
les gens que tu as féliciter comme ça
j'ai pas besoin de reprend et je
voudrais aussi m'associer un hommage de
nos deux héros que nous avons enterré
hier
merci pour eux
[Applaudissements]
mesdames mesdames et messieurs chers
amis nous voici arrivés à la dernière
ligne droite de cette campagne est pour
les élections européennes
et là je voudrais vous raconter une
petite histoire entre françois-xavier
moi nous ne connaissions pas du tout
j'ai entendu comme vous j'ai lu comme
vous ah oui mais siens jeunes c'est pas
il est trop catholique pratiquant il est
trop ceci trop cela et je dis bon le dis
à laurent
on va peut-être se rencontrer on s'est
rencontré en alsace
nous avons passé une soirée ensemble
avec tous les responsables européens et
les têtes de listes du parti populaire
européen
nous avons fait le voyage et après j'ai
dit à laurent laurent tu as choisi le
meilleur c'est un homme calme
c'est un homme qui écoute c'est un homme
qui ira loin
et donc je lui souhaite
[Applaudissements]
l'équipe de françois xavier
c'est ce qu'ils vont décider de la
direction à donner à l'euro ils devront
choisir et prendre les rênes de cette
europe
or qui mieux que les républicains pour
cela qui mieux que la famille populaire
européenne
nous avons mené le bateau européen
travers la tempête financière la crise
de la migration en engrangeant des
résultats extraordinaires avec nicolas
sarkozy
j étais en 2009 avec lui depuis où tout
le monde dit c'est une catastrophe c'est
une catastrophe
je vais quand même vous donner que trois
chiffres réduction de 90% des arrivées
illégal par rapport au pic de 2015
13 millions d'emplois créés en cinq ans
335 milliards d'euros d'investissements
mobilisés grâce aux plans ukr qui ont
profité à 700 mille pme directive qui en
a parlé sur les travailleurs détachés
que nous devons à notre commissaire ppe
marianne tyson pas à maquereau n'oubliez
pas de le dire
les chers amis nous devons être fiers de
nos réussites
nous devons être fiers de notre héritage
mais nous ne refusons pas pour autant de
nous complaire dans l'autosatisfaction
nous sommes déterminés à aller de
l'avant à faire avancer l'europe donc
aussi à changer ce qui ne va pas car ne
refusons pas de tomber dans le piège de
macron dans cette opposition stérile
entre pro européen et anti européens qui
pourraient douter de notre engagement de
notre amour pour l'europe
le ppe le parti des pères fondateurs le
parti de jean monnet et schuman à de
nombre de cas spiri et jeune homme bien
sûr pflimlin mon maire de strasbourg
le parti de tous ceux qui ont fait
avancer l'europe mais comme le dit
l'adage qui aime bien châtie bien
nous voulons donc ouvrir un nouveau
chapitre pour l'europe pour une europe
plus sûre qui protège ses citoyens une
europe prospère et juste pour tous qui
offre à chacun un avenir meilleur aussi
une robe durable qui allie politique
verte création d'emplois et défense de
l'industrie européenne une europe qui
défendent nos valeurs nos intérêts dans
le monde capable de parler d'une seule
voix et d'agir en concert une europe
avec une âme de nos concitoyens puissent
une fois de plus tomber amoureux
c'est ce que la jeune génération doit
réussir mes amis lorsque nous disons
bois si l'europe que nous voulons ce ne
sont pas des mots en l'air et en tant
que principale force politique en europe
nous avons non seulement la volonté mais
également les moyens de tenir nos
promesses siéger dans les rangs du ppe
donne donc aux députés plr
un poids dont aucun autre parti français
ne dispose d'ailleurs le déclin des taux
rice a débuté lorsqu'ils ont quitté le
groupe ppe est maintenant chez eux il
risque de se faire dépasser même par les
verts avec les nerfs la france à une loi
plus forte en europe d'ailleurs on
entend souvent dire
que la france est trop absente au niveau
de l'europe mes chers amis je suis
présent tous les jours en europe et je
représente aussi le ppe et la france en
europe
[Applaudissements]
notre président cher laurent qui
participe à tous les sommets aux côtés
de la chancelière merkel des présidents
tous que tajani et jonckheere la houle
encore dans nos positions avant chaque
conseil européen
nous avons donc une vision et nous avons
les instruments pour la réaliser qui
peut en dire autant de nos adversaires
regardez le président macro il avait
suscité tant d'attentes et d'espoirs en
europe et déçoit tout le monde pourquoi
parce qu'il ne connaît pas les réalités
européennes
il a débarqué en disant je les renverser
la table mais renverser la table
n'aboutit à rien c'est l'isolation de la
france qui est en train de se mettre en
place
et regardez ce qu'a encore dit
aujourd'hui angela merkel ii pour le
président matheron est derrière pour la
france pourrait réussir au niveau de
l'europe
il faut pas renverser la table il faut
rassembler les gens autour de la table
c'est comme ça qu'on réussit à faire
l'europe
[Applaudissements]
laurent et moi nous sommes
continuellement en contact
il connaît bien les rouages ils n'auront
je te remercie je lui dis la première
fois quand je mets vu laurent tu n'as
pas d'élections demain va visiter nos
amis dans l'ensemble des 27 pays
européens
c'est comme ça qu'on se fait des amis
c'est comme ça qu'on rassemble la
famille du ppe merci puisque tu as déjà
fait pas mal de tours au niveau des
différents pays européens
[Applaudissements]
les socialistes n'en parlons pas ils
sont de plus en plus divisés et ce n'est
pas une bonne chose pour l'europe
ils sont en crise d'identité les
libéraux
j'ai beaucoup de mal à comprendre leur
fonctionnement et les populistes
c'est dangereux la montée des populismes
pour l'union européenne pour la
construction de 60 années de paix et de
prospérité
nous pourrions tout casser dans les
quatre ou cinq années qui viennent si
les populistes prenait le pouvoir au
niveau de l'europe
mes chers amis battez vous pour les
prochaines élections il faut battre les
populistes
je ne veux pas être trop long vous savez
que ce qu'ont fait les personnes de
marine le pen au niveau de l'union
européenne
ça ne sert à rien heureusement
jusqu'aujourd'hui
alors continuons à nous battre pour que
demain aussi les populistes n'existe pas
au niveau de l'union européenne
d'ailleurs je vais vous dire une chose
st ils sont 1 passe incapables de
s'entendre sur quoi que ce soit ça c'est
notre chance et ça nous allons continuer
à l'exploiter
d'ailleurs madame le pen a attaqué avec
lémance le traité d'aix la chapelle
moi en tant qu'alsacien je peux vous
dire que l'amitié franco-allemande est
non seulement une partie fondamentale de
notre identité
elle est aussi la base sur laquelle
s'est construit l'europe et celle là il
ne faut surtout pas que monsieur macron
la casse il ne faut pas laisser casser
cette entente franco allemande
[Applaudissements]
c'est pour ça que je défends le siège de
strasbourg strasbourg c'est le symbole
de la réconciliation entre nos peuples
et nous allons continuer à défendre
strasbourg et ceux qui nous attaquent
qu'au niveau du ppe comme le premier
ministre hier je lui dis simplement
madame in belt qui paraît paraît-il dans
son nouveau groupe et je regarde mes
amis qui étaient au parlement
c'est la pire hantise strasbourgeoise
que je n'ai jamais vu alors qu'il fasse
d'abord le ménage à l'intérieur de son
groupe avant qu'ils veulent partie
parler du bpe
[Applaudissements]
mes amis le vote utile pour l' influence
de la france c'est le vote ait l'air et
l'air ppe pour le 26 mai et je suis sûr
[Applaudissements]
avec notre effort et mes chers amis ce
qu'il faut faire nous n'arriverons plus
jusqu'à 26 à faire voter les socialistes
pour nous mais nous arriverons avec ceux
qui pensent comme nous il faut qu'on les
amène aux urnes le 26
voilà l'objectif qu'on a voilà ce qu'il
faut faire les amis il faut emmener aux
yeux
ceux qui pensent que nous et qui votent
comme nous pour cette europe que nous
aimons et je suis sûr qu'ensemble le
d'annecy ce soir nous allons fêter la
victoire du ppe de notre spitz une
candidate
manfred weber et nous allons continuer à
construire cette belle europe et cette
belle construction de nos pères
fondateurs
merci beaucoup de m'avoir
[Applaudissements]